a book of precious photos and memories
iranian-born Lily mojer remembers the
1998 World Cup game in France between
Iran and the USA as if it were yesterday
yeah here is me my mom and the friends
and Iranian friend in Leon is just after
the match so we were very happy with our
shirts coming freshly from Iran
Lily's friend Ahmed fazeli was also in
the stadium today he's a wine cellar in
the city of Leon where the match took
place
I was so happy to be able to say that we
are Iranian playing the Americans
offered people hope for these two
countries that were tearing each other
apart
what's the FIFA draw that saw Iran and
the USA pitted together was clearly
welcomed by some fans but it caused a
diplomatic headache for organizers it
had been nearly two decades since the
Iranian Revolution ousted the U.S
backshar and relations between Tehran
and Washington were hostile both teams
were under pressure and in the spotlight
we had security 94 we have security
right now we've have Friday our Focus
for the game and nothing else Iran's
supreme leader forbade the Iranian team
to walk up to the Americans to shake
hands before the game so a compromise
was found the Iranians gave flowers and
the two sides posed for a photo during
the game there was a protest not against
the us but against Iran's government but
it didn't disrupt the match which ended
in a victory for Iran Tehran erupted in
celebrations
rugby matches are played here these days
but it was in this stadium in 1998 that
Iran beat USA 2-1 in one of the most
politically charged games in World Cup
history it was crazy amazing super the
game changed the image of Iran an
Iranian girl
with a painting of Iranian flag on her
cheek she was kissing an American
supporter you know and I mean it was
really really fun
Iran and USA meet once again in the
Qatar World Cup political tensions
remain high between the two countries
and tehran's Crackdown of
anti-government protests mean that Ahmad
and Lily say they'll watch the game but
with mixed feelings more than 20 years
After experiencing the excitement of
Iran's first ever World Cup win
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Leon